this video was made possible by blue
apron the first 100 people to sign up
using the link in the description get
three free delicious fresh meals from
blue apron in 2004 the american highway
users alliance published an article
claiming that the katy freeway in
houston texas was the second most
congested road in America drivers spent
a combined twenty five point four
million hours every year sitting in
traffic on that road
that's 36 life times worse it was an
absolute embarrassment of a road for
Texas so they decided to spend 2.8
billion dollars to expand it to 28 lanes
making it the widest highway in the
world all this extra capacity would
surely fix the problem more lanes means
more room for more cars which means
shorter travel times right unfortunately
not between 2011 and 2014 alone travel
times on the Katy Freeway increased by
up to 55 percent it now takes an average
of 64 minutes to drive the 28 miles
between downtown Houston and Katy Land
during the afternoon rush hour that's up
from 41 minutes in 2011 the problem with
this project was that the solution
violated the fundamental law of road
congestion more lanes mean more traffic
this probably seems counterintuitive the
more lanes there are the higher the
capacity road has so cars should be able
to drive faster but that's a very narrow
analysis of the problem you can't just
think about how this would work on one
road you have to think about it in the
context of a whole city many people
choose not to drive places because of
how long it takes if the traffic is bad
they can take public transit or wait
until a less busy time or just not
travel at all when a road is expanded
travel times
initially decrease so all those people
who chose not to drive or to take an
alternate route or whatever decide to
switch to using that newly expanded road
what's fascinating about roads is that
this happens at a perfect one-to-one
ratio if the capacity of a road doubles
the amount of people using that road
will also double if it doubles again
the amounts will again double
of course if you kept doing this over
and over again you would eventually
build a big enough red that there
wouldn't be any more cars to fill the
road but in the real world where demand
for roads far outstrip supply drivers
will adjust to any change in road
capacity so does that mean it's hopeless
is there no way to solve traffic no way
to make our roads better and safer and
more efficient well no there's plenty we
can do here's the thing about traffic it
slows down exponentially the 20,000th
car on the road slows down traffic
overall significantly more than the
5,000th car this is a major driver for a
lot of jams a small addition of cars
leads to a large addition in congestion
but it also makes solving traffic a bit
easier since you only need to remove a
small amount of cars from the road and
that's just what rant meters do ramp
meters are set up on the on ramps of
highways to restrict the amount of
people getting on the highway they
usually let one car on every five or six
seconds since the amount of cars
actually on the highway is kept down the
highway stays at its most efficient
speed Minnesota did an experiment where
they shut down their long used ramp
meters for eight weeks in order to see
if they actually worked and they found
that the highway capacity decreased by
9% travel times increased by 22% speeds
dropped by 7% and crashes increased by
26% stockholm sweden use that
exponential nature of traffic to
decrease travel times by up to 40% in
2006 stockholm is a city lies across 14
islands which means that all the bridges
act as huge choke points traffic
therefore was historically horrible for
this relatively small city On January
3rd 2006 Stockholm started to charge
drivers who entered this central
perimeter the busiest area the charge
wasn't much between 10 and 20 kronor the
equivalent of one and two US dollars but
it was enough to persuade 20% of drivers
to not enter the central perimeter they
either went downtown on public transport
or walked or didn't go at all these are
the amounts of daily drivers in the
perimeter and the years leading up to
the charge
as soon as the charge was implemented in
2006 the daily amount dropped down to
here it wasn't a fluke after the
six-month initial trial period driving
in the central core became free again
and the amount of daily drivers
increased to nearly the level it was
before when the charge became permanent
in 2007 daily numbers once again
plummeted even though the charge was
minuscule it was enough to dissuade tens
of thousands of people from using those
roads there are really two cost of
driving the money and the time when the
time it takes to drive isn't enough of a
cost to prevent people from driving
these charges increase the overall cost
to a level where some people will decide
not to drive but what about safety roads
are still unbelievably dangerous in any
given year one out of every 10,000
people in the US die in a car accident
just think about how high of a
proportion that is if you go to a
Redskins game at FedEx Field near
Washington DC eight of the people
sitting in the stands with you will die
in the next year in a car accident it
turns out one of the best ways to
prevent accidents is with something you
almost certainly already seen or used
the roundabout there's a reason you see
these more and more roundabouts reduce
deaths and serious injuries by 90
percent that is not an error with
roundabouts there's almost no
opportunity for the worst type of
collision the head-on
full-speed crash in a traditional
intersection cars come within feet of
each other while going at a relative
speed of up to 100 miles per hour a
head-on crash at that speed is
undoubtedly catastrophic with
roundabouts cars naturally slow down to
about 15 to 25 miles per hour since
they're going around a curve also if
there were to be a collision it would
either be a side-impact collision if a
car failed to turn into the circle or a
side to side collision of a car
misjudged the curve both of these
collisions happen at a low relative
speed so fatalities are low but what
about capacity surely the lower speed
roundabouts cause horrible traffic
problems
well they don't a single lane
roundabouts can handle a maximum of
1,800 vehicles per hour which is exactly
the same as a
additional two-lane signaled
intersection while cars will move
through a signaled intersection at a
much higher speed they have to wait both
for the light to change and left turning
cars with roundabouts
you have a smooth consistent albeit
slower flow so what's the problem why
haven't we replaced every intersection
with a roundabout well there are
disadvantages they're more difficult for
pedestrians especially those who are
deaf or blind they require a larger
footprint they're more expensive to
maintain but the real reason roundabouts
are not ubiquitous nowadays is because
of the biggest fallacy in road design
that drivers need rules pointin just
outside of Manchester UK used to have a
typical rather dreary intersection and
nobody really liked it cars would back
up for miles pedestrians had to wait
forever for the light to change and it
essentially split the town apart so
someone had the idea to remove the
traffic lights remove the zebra
crossings the curbs remove almost every
safety device in the intersection and
just set up two adjoining roundabouts
surely this would wreak havoc but it
didn't turns out when people are
uncomfortable when people aren't really
sure what's going on they pay more
attention the green light was a signal
to people that the road was clear that
it was safe to speed that they could let
their guard down but after the change
the cars were able to flow freely albeit
at a slow pace instead of waiting for
the lights to change pedestrian
incidents went down collisions went down
traffic flowed faster and the city
centre finally had some character so all
around the world cities are replicating
what pointen did they're removing curbs
traffic lights and pedestrian crossings
to make one shared space all around the
world these streets are resulting in
fewer accidents and more pedestrian
space discomfort is saving lives on a
larger scale there's one more innovative
intersection design that's beginning to
save lives the diverging diamond
interchange this interchange is designed
as a way to get more cars on and off the
highways faster after the on-ramp to the
right side the road crosses over so cars
never have to traverse active lanes to
get onto the highway a car heading north
can effortlessly join the on-ramp
without crossing traffic and a car
heading south will cross over so it
drives on the
left side and can effortlessly join the
on-ramp to head south not only is this
easier for drivers it improves safety
the dangerousness of an intersection is
often rated by determining the number of
conflict points possible points where
accidents could happen under normal
circumstances with a traditional on-ramp
intersection there are 26 with a
diverging diamond intersection only 14
and they're faster to the US Department
of Transportation found in a study that
universally whether the traffic was
light or heavy diverging diamond
interchanges let more cars through
faster it cost less to a traditional
on-ramp intersection requires eleven
point three million dollars to build a
diverging diamond intersection only five
point seven million dollars there are
really no major disadvantages to this
intersection so nearly 100 of them have
been built a date and more and more are
being installed each month as good as
the solutions sound there's no one way
to solve traffic the difference between
cities with chronic traffic problems and
those without is a combination of smart
policies and designs that mitigate the
effects of having more Road demand than
supply but traffic won't just fix itself
so until cities at least experiment with
solutions were all condemned to traffic
forever
fixing traffic is all about saving time
and proving the environment and so is
blue apron they ship pre apportioned
meals straight to your doorstep sourced
directly from sustainable farms and
fisheries blue apron sent me a box to
try out and it was a fantastic meal your
shipped the exact amount of everything
you need so you don't have to do any
measuring not only does this save time
and also minimizes food waste they give
you these clear concise instructions so
even the least experienced chefs can
work with their recipes so here's the
meal I made it was healthy quick filling
and delicious and the good news is that
you can get a meal just like this for
free blue apron is offering the first
100 Wendover productions viewers that
sign up with the link in the description
three free meals so you can try blue
apron not only will signing up support
one of our productions you'll also get a
chance to try these truly delicious meal
aside from that please be sure to check
out my podcast show makers and subscribe
to this channel to get all my future
videos right when they come out thanks
again for watching and I'll see you in
two weeks for another Wendover
productions video